Today's experiment is sponsored by HelloFresh. Hey guys
I'm Nate and today we have taken a coconut, made a mold of it,
And we're going to see if we can make a candy coconut using chocolate, white chocolate, and Sprite. you can hear liquid swishing around inside
It and when you crack it open
You can see the shell, the meat, and the liquid just like a real coconut. This box mold should seal up nice and watertight
But just to make sure it doesn't fall apart while we're molding in it. Let's use some tape wrapped around it to hold it closed
With the Box taped up you'll now be able to pour the melted chocolate in and swirl it around without any worry about it leaking out the sides
To get the right color for the shell. I think milk chocolate is the clear winner
Ice and liquid looking chocolate once you've got your chocolate nice and liquid from the microwave
Pour in much more than you're going to need to make sure you can swirl it around and get a nice even coat inside
Now you want to make sure you pour out any excess chocolate so you don't have a shell, that's an inch thick--that's no good
To get a nice even coating it helps if you can keep the block rotating every once in a while while the chocolate cools down
As soon as it gets to a point where it's not really runny anymore
And it's not swirling around the sides you should put it in the fridge for
15 to 30 minutes to help it cool down so that it doesn't get melted by the next layer
With the first layer nice and cool
It's time to add another one
One one layer of this chocolate may not be quite thick enough to represent the shell of the coconut you can easily have two bags
Of the chocolate to microwave and pour into your mold
I didn't use all the chocolate from my first bag, so instead of using a second one
I kept it in a small bowl
Surrounded by hot water that did a really good job of keeping the chocolate nice and liquid as our shell cooled down
So now it's time to repeat the same process
Pour too much chocolate into the mold
Swirl it around until it coats everything and then pour out the excess
Keep it swirling until it's coated everything and the chocolate has started cool
And then pop it back in the fridge for another 15 to 30 minutes
Two layers of the milk chocolate should be enough to build up a nice
shell around our coconut
So now it's time to do the meat of the coconut the white portion
This of course is thicker than the shell in a coconut
So we're going to try and do three or maybe even four layers of the white chocolate inside our mouth chocolate
With the white chocolate we need to do the same thing we did with the milk chocolate
Pour it in more of the white chocolate then we're going to need swirl
It around so it coats every edge pour out the extra and then pop it in the fridge
After the last pour you'll want to leave the mold and the casting in the fridge for at least an hour
We really want it to cool down inside
We're gonna be using some sprite as the liquid inside the coconut, but if there's too much carbonation
Then when we try and seal the coconut off all the pressure is going to break it apart
So we really need to make this some very flat soda
So let's pour some of this off into a cup and then pop it in the vacuum chamber
To really pull out all the extra carbonation
That might have been a little bit more than was necessary
We did have a little bit more liquid in the cup than I was anticipating so we had some spillage, but I
Believe what we have in this cup is probably just the right amount of very flat
Lemon-lime soda give it a quick taste see if there's any fizz left in it
No
No, there's not while we're waiting for the mold and casting you cool down
We can throw the cup in the fridge with them, so the liquid is cold as well
At this point the casting inside the mold should be all cooled down, and we have some very flat
Pool sprite which at this point really looks just like water
But it is still lemon-lime flavored so that's gonna count
We do want to patch this hole up after we fill the sprite, so I do still have some of our milk and white chocolate
Let's clean up all the edges pour the sprite in and then see what we can do about patching it up
using some of our extra chocolate your goes let's try adding our flat sprite into our candy coconut
It's not filling it all the way
But that's what we want you can hear the empty space sloshing around inside the coconut
So we're not going for 100% full because we do want to get that sound of liquid jostling around in there
That's pretty full and I think it will do a pretty good job of emulating the inside of coconut now
Let's take some of our extra white and milk chocolate and try and seal it in there
With all of the chocolate cooled down nicely inside our mold it is time to remove it and
Reveal our coconut within but first let's learn about our sponsors. If you like to cook at home hello
Fresh is a great way to do it. They've really set up a system
That's convenient to use if you have a busy schedule you can choose the delivery day that works best for you
If you're going to be out of town you can pause your account for weeks at a time
All of the ingredients come pre measured in handy labelled meal kits so you know which ingredients go with which recipe
Unlike at a grocery store and of course the whole kit is delivered right to your door in
Recyclable insulated packaging hellofresh offers a wide variety of chef's curated recipes that are different every week
they have the classic veggie and
Family plans to choose from the recipes are designed to only take about 30 minutes to prep so you're not gonna have to spend all
Night in the kitchen cooking
Several of the meals are designed to be one pot recipes for speedy cooking and minimal cleanup each week one meal in the classic menu
Is designed to only take 20 minutes to prep?
I thought the instructions were easy to follow prep time was quick and the quality of the food was excellent
It's a really convenient and easy service to use knowing that you're getting full meals in just the right portion sizes for
$30 off your first week of hellofresh visit hellofresh comm and enter promo code king of random 30 I
Can hear the liquid sloshing around that's a good side
The tricky part of course is getting the coconut out of the mold without breaking it hopefully
We've got a nice strong shell and interior made of five layers of cast chocolates
Yes
Half a coconut
That is half of a coconut
This is the easier side to get off because the back of our coconut has all of this husk bit on it and it makes
For a much more grippy side of the mold
still
If it's a very good start, I'm seeing a little bit of leakage I
Think our sprite is making it out of the stopper
Change up our angle of attack just a little bit keep it vertical
Yes
haha
now for the most part
This is looking good our pour spout as you can see is still a little bit sloppy
And it's very hard to work with the chocolate inside the mold
So let's just level off our pour spout and touch it up with a bit more of the milk chocolate
Well let's look at our comparison test between the Real coconut and the chocolate coconut they have about the same weight
Which I think is a good sign. They're obviously the same size and shape since one is molded and cast off of the other I
Hear liquid sloshing around in that one I
Hear liquid sloshing around in that one at this point what we really need to do is see the inside
So let's crack this sucker open
I am told the best way to crack a coconut is to strike it against a sharp rock perpendicular to the seam
Opposite the largest of the three portions, so that's right here. We've got ourselves a sharp rock
I'll try it with the real coconut first, and then see how the chocolate coconut reacts
There it is let's put pretty nicely in half right there Cheers
So that's what happens with the real coconut pretty good half split now
Let's see if we have a similar result with our chocolate. I know that the chocolate is more fragile
I just don't know how much more fragile
Just like our real coconut though. This is full of liquid so it's gonna spill out quite a bit
I'm hoping I have a nice big piece kind of like this that I can catch some of the liquid in and drink it out
it
here goes I
Guess this is harder than I anticipated all right. I'm gonna try this again. I'm just gonna hit harder one two three
Think the chocolate is harder than the real coconut
Oh
Oh, it's cracking there. We go. Oh there it is
our chocolate coconut insides
Well the two liquids definitely didn't taste the same one of course tasted like coconut water and the other one tasted like flat sprite, but
The shell on the chocolate one
Is a lot better
Now this doesn't have a perfectly even distribution of the chocolate unsurprisingly
It's a lot thicker down at the bottom where I would set it down to cool even though I tried to let the chocolate cool
Down before I put it into the refrigerator
I guess it was still slumping a little bit so we have thinner walls near the for spout thicker walls near the bottom
But overall I'd say that it's unmistakably a coconut
Thanks again to our sponsor for this video. Hello. Fresh check the link in the description below for a discount off of your first order